Hasta ahora, la guerra de Ucrania parece la
versión moderna del mito de David contra
Goliat.
Casi un año después de que los tanques rusos
estuvieran en las puertas de Kyiv, ahora son
los rusos los que parecen estar contra las
cuerdas.
Pero...
¿Y si Moscú estuviese intentando a cualquier
precio revertir la situación?
¿Podrían volver a cambiar las tornas?
Pues…
Atentos a esta noticia.
(Rusia completa la movilización parcial de
ciudadanos para la guerra de Ucrania)
Esta noticia es de noviembre de 2022.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo,
enero de 2023, todavía no se sabe exactamente
cuántos nuevos soldados ha movilizado Rusia.
Pero el objetivo eran 300.000.
Si esto fuera así, estaríamos hablando de
casi el doble de los soldados que comenzaron
la invasión en febrero del año pasado ¡Pero
no sólo eso!
Algunos dicen que las cifras podrían ser
aún mayores.
(Ucrania dice que Rusia se prepara para movilizar
otros 500.000 reclutas extra - The Guardian)
¿Hasta qué punto esto es cierto?
¡No lo sabemos!
Pero todo señala que algo se está cociendo
y si la inteligencia ucraniana no se equivoca,
Rusia tendría ya a más de 280.000 tropas
en el campo de batalla... y ahora podría
querer sumar otros 500.000 más.
Es decir, podríamos llegar a hablar de más
de 700 mil soldados en combate o listos para
entrar en batalla.
Eso podría explicar, por ejemplo, por qué
el arranque del 2023 ha sido frenético, prácticamente
cada día se anuncian enormes envíos de armas
pesadas y misiles avanzados a Ucrania por
parte de Estados Unidos, Reino Unido y demás
países aliados.
Dinamarca, por ejemplo, le ha entregado a
Ucrania el grueso de su artillería.
Fijaos.
(Dinamarca donará a Ucrania 19 obuses autopropulsados
César de fabricación francesa.
Defense Post)
Hay que preparar a Ucrania, 500 mil soldados
más reclutados son muchos soldados…
Pero…
respecto a Rusia ¡Ya sé lo que muchos estaréis
pensando!
¿Cómo les han podido entrenar en tan poco
tiempo?
Si en 2022, con los arsenales llenos de material,
los rusos tuvieron problemas logísticos ¿Cómo
van a armar y alimentar a tantísimas personas?
Pues sí, tenéis razón: enviar tantas tropas
no es tarea fácil.
Y, como veremos más adelante en este vídeo,
la movilización parcial de Putin ha sido
de todo menos un camino de rosas.
Ahora bien, seguimos hablando de cientos de
miles de nuevos soldados.
Podrán estar mejor o peor armados, con mejor
o peor entrenamiento o con más o menos equipamiento
pero como mínimo hay que mirar estas cifras
con respeto.
Si finalmente se produce esta movilización
es una cifra lo suficientemente alta como
para que les dediquemos un vídeo aquí en
VisualPolitik.
Así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es
¿De verdad han sido capaces de reclutar a
tanta gente en Rusia?
¿Cómo lo han hecho?
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener esto para
el Kremlin?
¿Hasta qué punto deberían preocuparse en
Kyiv?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(TODO VALE PARA EL CONVENTO
El 20 de septiembre, la Duma (que es el parlamento
ruso) aprobó la Ley de Movilización.
Rusia necesita 300.000 nuevos reclutas.
Y la pregunta que muchos os estaréis haciendo
es ¿Qué significa esto exactamente?
Es decir ¿A partir de ahora, se puede enviar
a cualquier ciudadano a la guerra?
¿Cómo se ha hecho esta movilización?
Pues bien, lo primero que tenemos que tener
en cuenta es que no todos los rusos pueden
ser llamados a filas: el primer requisito
es tener experiencia militar previa.
Por ejemplo, si luchaste en la guerra de Georgia
de 2008, te podrían llamar de nuevo.
Tendrías que pasar un examen médico y podrías
verte obligado a irte a Ucrania ¿Que intentas
escaparte?
Pues prepárate, porque puedes terminar con
penas de entre 3 o 10 años de cárcel.
Hasta aquí, todo normal: no deja de ser una
guerra.
Además, el sueldo prometido por Putin no
está nada mal.
Putin ha dicho que cada movilizado cobrará
195.000 rublos, un equivalente a más o menos
3.000 dólares mensuales.
Claro eso es en teorí a, la práctica puede
llegar a ser muy diferente.
(100 soldados rusos reclutados se declararon
en huelga y se negaron a luchar en Ucrania
después de que no se les pagase, según un
informe - Business Insider)
Como os podéis imaginar, el primer problema
con una movilización como está es el coste
político.
Es de cajón, ¡Muy pocos están felices con
ir a la guerra!
Así que tan pronto como el Kremlin hizo el
anuncio de la primera movilización, se organizaron
las primeras protestas en las principales
ciudades del país.
Y de hecho, desde entonces Putin ha reducido
considerablemente sus apariciones en público.
Por ejemplo, cada final de año el presidente
ruso solía hacer una conferencia de prensa
con preguntas del público.
En 2022 esa tradición llegó a su fin.
La conferencia se canceló.
Pero la pregunta ahora es: ¿Cómo se pueden
reclutar a 300.000 personas primero y, si
finalmente ocurre, a medio millón más en
un país tan grande como Rusia?
Pues bien, cada región rusa tiene centros
de reclutamiento, al que se les ponen unas
cuotas.
Estos son los mismos centros de reclutamiento
por donde pasan los 260.000 jóvenes que hacen
el servicio militar cada año.
¡Y aquí es donde viene el segundo gran problema!
Como os podéis imaginar, muchos rusos no
quieren morir en Ucrania.
A estas alturas, todos habréis oído hablar
del éxodo masivo de jóvenes rusos que se
han escapado del país para evitar ir a la
guerra.
Hablamos de más de 700.000 personas ¿Y qué
creéis que ha pasado con los que no han conseguido
escaparse?
Pues, en muchos casos, cosas como esta.
(Desde la invasión de Ucrania, se han reportado
más de una docena de intentos de quemar oficinas
de reclutamiento en distintas regiones rusas.
Meduza, 22 septiembre de 2022)
¡Habéis oído bien!
No sólo hablamos de protestas.
Hablamos de gente que ha llegado a tirar cócteles
molotov contra las oficinas de reclutamiento.
Hemos visto vídeos de protestas, quejas de
reclutas, etc...
Vamos, que esta movilización masiva no ha
sido tarea fácil.
Sin embargo, para el 28 de octubre de 2022,
el Ministro de Defensa anunció que la primera
movilización había terminado con éxito.
Y la pregunta que todos os estaréis haciendo
es ¿De verdad fueron capaces de movilizar
a 300.000 soldados o es otro farol de los
muchos que lleva tirándose Rusia en esta
guerra?
Pensadlo así: todos los años, el ejército
ruso hace dos campañas de reclutamiento.
Una en primavera y otra en otoño.
Estas dos campañas duran alrededor de 3 meses.
Aquí se movilizan unos 130.000 jóvenes.
Sin embargo, ahora estamos hablando de movilizar
a más del doble de personas en menos de la
mitad de tiempo y en mitad de protestas y
ataques con cócteles molotov ¿De verdad
es posible hacer algo así?
Pues bien: lo que ya están diciendo muchos
expertos es que Rusia sí puede movilizar
a 300.000 reservistas ¡Pero con muchas comillas!
Por una parte, se han incluido a criminales
que estaban en prisión.
También se han cometido “errores” ((lanzar
gesto de comillas al aire)) como enviar a
soldados que superaban el límite de edad.
Pero todo eso son cosas que incluso el Kremlin
ha reconocido.
Sin embargo, hay sospechas de que el quid
de la cuestión no es exactamente este.
Y es que, veréis, en teoría, esta movilización
intentaba reenganchar a reservistas con experiencia
en combate o que, al menos, han sido soldados
profesionales: no simples reclutas.
Pensad que, en Rusia, casi todos los hombres
de entre 18 y 27 años tienen que hacer un
servicio militar obligatorio que dura 12 meses.
Es decir, que ahora mismo hay 127.500 reclutas
que están a punto de terminar sus 12 meses
de servicio y volver a sus trabajos civiles
¿Están preparados para entrar en combate?
Pues no.
Pero los centros de reclutamiento necesitan
cumplir con las cuotas que les han impuesto.
Y si sois veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik,
ya sabéis que la administración rusa se
caracteriza por una cosa: mentiras y más
mentiras.
Los directores de los centros quieren tener
contentos a sus superiores, que a su vez quieren
tener contentos al alto estado mayor... y
así sucesivamente
¿Conclusión?
¡Traemos a estos reclutas que están a punto
de irse a casa...
les ponemos un contrato de soldado profesional
y les mandamos para Ucrania!
¿De cuántos reclutas estamos hablando?
¿Se está haciendo de forma frecuente?¡No
lo podemos saber!
Pero los rumores existen.
Y desde luego esta no es una teoría para
nada descabellada.
Ahora bien, con más o menos experiencia,
hablamos de decenas y decenas de miles, cientos
de miles de personas que poco a poco llegarán
al campo de batalla Y la pregunta es, ¿hasta
que punto pueden inclinar la balanza hacia
Rusia?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
( ¿UNA PICADORA DE CARNE?)
Según el gobierno ruso para finales de octubre
y comienzos de noviembre del 2023 la primera
movilización ya había cumplido su objetivo.
Desde entonces decenas y decenas de miles
de estos nuevos soldados han sido trasladados
a Ucrania.
Y la pregunta ahora es ¿Para qué ha movilizado
Rusia tantas personas?
Pues bien, como puede parecer obvio el primer
objetivo ha sido reforzar las debilitadas
líneas rusas lo que ha facilitado que en
cierta forma el frente se estanque o incluso
que los rusos hayan vuelta a intentar llevar
a cabo algunas pequeñas ofensivas.
Pero, además, se cree que Rusia está planeando
un segundo gran ataque a Ucrania.
Algunos hablan de una ofensiva que empezaría
a finales del invierno, otros creen que se
esperarán hasta primavera.
Algunos dicen que se limitarán al Donbás,
pero la inteligencia ucraniana habla de un
nuevo ataque a Kyiv, que se produciría desde
Bielorrusia.
C1(“Los rusos están preparando tropas frescas,
no tengo dudas de que irán otra vez por Kyiv”
- Oleksandr Syrsky, Coronel General Ucraniano)
Claro que, una cosa es reclutar personas y
otra muy distinta es prepararlas, organizarlas
y equiparlas.
Y creo que todos sabemos que Rusia está teniendo
muchísimos problemas para eso.
Es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado aquí
en VisualPolitik en pasados vídeos.
Además, los gerifaltes rusos, no sólo están
pensado en los reclutamientos, también se
ha visto cómo Rusia está preparando tanques
T-62, de los años 60, para enviarlos a Ucrania.
Y eso en cierta forma es un serio problema.
Por muchos soldados que logren movilizar,
lo más probable es que el grueso del armamento
pesado que manden a Ucrania, de intentar otro
golpe, sea morralla con alguna pieza más
moderna suelta por aquí y por allá para
las misiones más complejas.
Porque lo cierto es que pese a todas las bajas
y pérdidas sufridas a Rusia todavía le queda
mucha morralla soviética por soltar.
Sea como sea, desde el Instituto para el estudio
de la guerra, han reportado que las tropas
rusas están trasladando más equipamiento
pesado.
El traslado está siendo desde la retaguardia
de Luhansk, hacia áreas cercanas a la actual
línea de frente entre Kharviv y Lugansk.
Y de hecho es en esta región donde probablemente
se centren los rusos, así como en el Óblast
de Donetsk, donde intentarían capturar la
totalidad de la región.
A lo largo de estas líneas, por ejemplo,
ya se están realizando algunas operaciones
limitadas para frenar los avances ucranianos
y recuperar posiciones perdidas en el frente
de Kreminná.
Y algo muy parecido dice el propio ministro
de asuntos exteriores de Ucrania, Dmytro Kuleba.
Todos esperan una gran ofensiva rusa en los
primeros meses de 2023.
Sin embargo, debido al poco entrenamiento
de muchos de los movilizados, tampoco se espera
demasiado de ellos ¡Y ya sé lo que pensará
alguno!
¡Ya están los de VisualPolitik con su propaganda
anti-rusa!
Pues para nada.
De hecho, algunos movilizados sí pueden servir
para mucho al ejército ruso.
Por ejemplo, aquellos con experiencia anterior
en profesiones como la mecánica o la medicina
pueden ser de gran ayuda.
Pero en líneas generales en toda guerra,
y más aún en las guerras modernas, el entrenamiento
y la experiencia es un elemento muy importante.
No todos los soldados tienen el mismo nivel
combativo.
Y vale, es cierto que una parte de los movilizados
fueron enviados al frente mientras que el
resto se quedaron entrenando en Rusia.
Sin embargo hasta ahora no podemos decir que
haya salido demasiado bien la primera toma
de contacto…
Y los que siguen entrenando tampoco es que
vayan a tener mucho tiempo.
Este es un handicap importante que explica
por qué en la mayoría de los casos la movilización
se ha convertido en un verdadero infierno
para los rusos que la han sufrido.
Literalmente, la mayoría no son más que
carne que termina siendo lanzada por Putin
a un avispero para hacer bulto en el frente
y tratar de retrasar a los ucranianos, quizás
esperando a que el fin del invierno juegue
a su favor.
Evidentemente las expectativas de esta gente
son bastante malas Y, de hecho, muchos de
ellos lob saben perfectamente.
C2(“Dos semanas de entrenamiento no te preparan
para esto” - Declaraciones de un movilizado
ruso para The Guardian)
Ahí tenemos el caso de Aleksei Agafonov,
que fue movilizado junto a otros 570 hombres
de la región de Vorónezh.
En una entrevista que dio a The Guardian,
contó su desastrosa experiencia al frente.
Entre otras cosas, declaró que de los 570
reclutados, a las pocas semanas solo 130 continuaban
con vida.
C3(“Muchos de los que sobrevivieron perdieron
la cabeza después de los que paso, nadie
quiere volver.
[...] Estábamos completamente expuestos”
- Declaraciones de un movilizado ruso a The
Guardian)
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
el mayor problema!
Cierto: todo apunta a que estos movilizados
no están bien entrenados.
Pero la siguiente pregunta que nos deberíamos
hacer es...
¿Cómo van a ir armados?
Pues… en fin, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(¿DE DÓNDE SALDRÁN LAS ARMAS?)
Hay una pregunta que voy a dejar en el aire.
Haced la suma: 700.000 rusos se han ido del
país, otros 300.000 se van a Ucrania; en
total hablamos de 1 millón de trabajadores
que se han ido del país.
Estamos hablando tranquilamente de más del
1,4% de la población activa del país y algo
más del 2% si finalmente se produce un segundo
reclutamiento.
Y eso son palabras mayores…
Sobre todo cuándo tenemos en cuenta que entre
los rusos que han huido se encuentran muchos
jóvenes altamente cualificados.
Y si a esta pérdida le sumamos que la sociedad
rusa está profundamente envejecida, la pregunta
es ¿Cómo va a poder producir riqueza la
economía rusa?
¿Quién va a fabricar esas armas que tanto
necesitan?
Sí, es cierto: uno de los grupos excluidos
de la movilización son los que trabajan en
empresas de armamento.
Pero esto no es suficiente.
Y... ¡Ojo!
Porque esto es algo que reconocen las propias
autoridades rusas.
Atentos.
(La escasez de personal en las empresas de
defensa rusa es de alrededor de 400.000 personas)
Aunque esto no es algo nuevo, en otros videos
ya os hemos comentado los problemas armamentísticos
de Rusia.
En 2017, NPO Novator, una compañía armamentística
rusa, solo era capaz de producir 60 misiles
en 6 meses.
Y, claro, como os podéis imaginar, la intensidad
de la guerra de Ucrania requiere algo más
que eso
Por ejemplo, para que os hagáis una idea,
en varias ocasiones Rusia ha llegado a lanzar
más del doble de esa cantidad de misiles
en un solo día.
(Y no solo eso,se estima que tan solo en noviembre
de 2022, Rusia disparó cerca de 20.000 rondas
de artillería.
Además, en un mes han llegado a lanzar nada
más y nada menos que 1.200 misiles Kalibr.
Según el Royal United Services Institute
(RUSI), Rusia llegó a disparar en dos días
más municiones que las que Reino Unido tiene
en sus reservas regulares.
Además, las fuerzas rusas ya utilizaron casi
el total de sus misiles de corto alcance Iskander
Vamos, que el ejército ruso tiene simultáneamente
dos grandes problemas: disparan artillería
a un ritmo muy rápido y tienen problemas
para producir más al ritmo necesario.
Y es que al contrario de lo que quizás pensaba
Putin, China no le ha vendido armas de forma
masiva como se había especulado al comienzo
de la guerra.
Y si esto ya es en sí preocupante para Rusia,
hay otro factor que les pone las cosas aún
peor: las sanciones internacionales.
Pensadlo así: una cosa son las balas convencionales
que usamos para un rifle y otra muy distinta,
los misiles de precisión.
Para fabricar balas normales, Rusia tiene
los materiales y lo único que le puede fallar
un poco es la industria y el ritmo de producción,
pero...
¿Qué pasa con los misiles de precisión?
¡Ay, amigo!
Aquí estamos hablando de un juego totalmente
distinto.
Gran parte de los misiles rusos están equipados
con microchips tradicionalmente suministrados
por Occidente.
Eso significa que debido a las sanciones,
Rusia se está quedando sin misiles de precisión
por la escasez de estos chips.
(Las armas rusas en Ucrania están alimentadas
por cientos de componentes occidentales, según
un informe - Reuters)
Y es que claro, la mayoría de esas piezas
occidentales se fabrican en solo unos pocos
países.
Principalmente hablamos de Taiwán, Corea
del Sur, Estados Unidos, Países Bajos, Alemania,
Reino Unido y Japón.
Es por esto que en Rusia hemos empezado a
ver todo tipo de chapuzas armamentísticas
que parecen sacadas de una película de risa..
C4(“Tenemos informes de los ucranianos de
que cuando encuentran equipos militares rusos,
están llenos de semiconductores que sacaron
de lavavajillas y neveras”
Gina Raimondo, secretaria de comercio de Estados
Unidos.)
Quién sabe, igual eso explica las imágenes
que hemos visto de casas ucranianas totalmente
desvalijadas sin frigoríficos ni lavadoras
tras el paso de las tropas rusas.
Quien sabe…
Pero, claro, teniendo todo esto en cuenta,
la pregunta es ¿Qué está haciendo Putin
para cambiar esto?
Pues bien, dadas las sanciones, en realidad
Putin tiene muy poco margen de maniobra.
Por ahora, el dictador ruso está aprovechándose
de su buena relación con Irán.
¿Un ejemplo?
Los constantes ataques con drones iraníes
que ya se han vuelto algo cotidiano en la
guerra en Ucrania.
Y, ojo, porque a los drones le siguen los
misiles balísticos de corto alcance de tipo
Fateh-110 y Zolfaghar.
Por eso, como respuesta a la venta de armas
de Irán, algunos países como el Reino Unido
ya han introducido nuevos paquetes de sanciones
no solo contra altos jerifaltes del Ejército
ruso, sino también contra empresarios y funcionarios
iraníes.
El propio secretario de Estado de Estados
Unidos, Anthony Blinken, dijo esto:
C5 ("Estados Unidos seguirá usando toda herramienta
a su alcance para interrumpir dichas transferencias
e imponer consecuencias a aquellos involucrados
en esas actividades" Anthony Blinken, Secretario
de Estado de Estados Unidos)
Por otro lado, desde Estados Unidos ha habido
acusaciones de compra de armas por parte de
Rusia a Corea del norte.
Acusaciones que, cómo no, han sido tachadas
por Rusia de puras "habladurías y especulaciones".
El caso es que con o sin los norcoreanos,
los rusos ya han empezado a usar munición
degradada.
En algunos casos, estaríamos hablando de
cohetes y balas fabricadas hace 40 años.
Y lo que pasa cuando usas cosas viejas, pues
se puede esperar: hay proyectiles que se atascan
en los obuses rusos... y otros que son lanzados
pero no explotan cuando alcanza su objetivo.
¡Pero mucho ojo, no os equivoqueis!
Esto puede ser algo bueno, una ventaja para
Kyiv en el desarrollo de la guerra, pero lo
cierto es que no son buenas noticias para
Ucrania a largo plazo.
Por un lado es verdad que es difícil ganar
una guerra con munición desfasada, pero esto
también significa que los proyectiles que
todavía no han explotado pueden hacerlo más
adelante en circunstancias indeseadas.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Dado que Rusia está siendo incapaz de ganar
la guerra, ahora está empezando a señalar
y atacar objetivos más “fáciles”, aunque
ello suponga perpetrar crímenes de lesa humanidad.
Estoy, por supuesto, hablando de los objetivos
civiles.
Algo que ahora Rusia está empezando a buscar
para desanimar la resistencia ucraniana.
(El ataque de misiles ruso contra un edificio
de apartamentos en Dnipro mata a 40 personas,
según dicen las autoridades ucranianas)
Pensadlo así ¿Qué utilidad tiene destruir
un edificio de viviendas?
Desde el punto de vista de la guerra, ninguna
¿Por qué los cazas de combate rusos planean
un ataque así?
La razón es simple: no pueden hacer otra
cosa y con estos ataques tan crueles esperan
poder desanimar la resistencia y forzar a
Ucrania a aceptar un alto el fuego conveniente
para Moscú.
Es, exactamente lo mismo que han estado con
las centrales eléctricas o las plantas de
tratamiento de agua.
(Concretamente, el ataque de Dnipro se realizó
con misiles KH-22.
Estos misiles son de la época soviética.
Se caracterizan por dos cosas: son muy poco
precisos pero, a la vez, son casi imposibles
de interceptar por Ucrania.
Al menos, con el arsenal que tienen ahora
¿Conclusión?
Rusia los ha utilizado en varias ocasiones
para atacar zonas muy pobladas.
De nuevo: no destruyen un objetivo militar
concreto pero basta con que caigan en una
ciudad para que maten a decenas de civiles.)
El caso es que llegados hasta aquí puede
que muchos estéis pensando… pero entonces,
¿está Rusia condenada a perder esta guerra?
¿Todos esos cientos de miles de nuevos soldados
van a ir directamente a una picadora de carne?
Pues, en cierto modo, sí.
Ahora bien, también tenemos que mirar la
otra cara de la moneda: Ucrania depende totalmente
de las ayudas de Occidente para armar a su
ejército.
Y aunque hasta ahora el suministro de armamento
a Ucrania ha sido constante, y todo apunta
a que seguirá siendo así, lo cierto es que
al final esto es algo que no depende de los
ucranianos sino de la solidaridad internacional.
Y esto podría llegar a ser un problema, o
como poco, una importante debilidad.
Y segundo,aunque Occidente continúe suministrando
munición el arsenal de Europa y Estados Unidos
también tiene sus límites.
Y la situación ahora mismo está lejos de
ser ideal…
Al menos en lo que concierte a determinados
equipos.
Y aunque parece que todavía no estamos en
un punto alarmante, lo cierto es que noticias
como esta son importantes tomárselas en serio.
(Europa está enviando armas a Ucrania rápidamente
pero se está quedando sin munición.)
Al menos en lo relativo a Europa occidental,
que es la que tiene ejércitos peor equipados.
Quizás la única excepción sea el Reino
Unido.
Estados Unidos, por su parte, está echando
mano de los gigantescos almacenes que tenía
en Israel y en Corea del Sur para situaciones
de guerra.
Esto por sí mismo debería servir para cubrir
las necesidades de munición convencional.
Sea como sea, todavía no estamos en un punto
crítico.
Las últimas entregas de armas son una buena
prueba de ello.
Todavía quedan muchos almacenes repletos.
Y eso por no hablar de toda la industria militar
occidental.
Pero, llegados a este punto, la pregunta es
para vosotros ¿Está Ucrania preparada para
lo que parece que viene?
¿Creéis que los rusos reclutados van a cambiar
la dinámica de la guerra?
Podéis dejarnos vuestras opiniones aquí
abajo, en los comentarios.
Y como siempre no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.